[Musique]
je vous emmène aujourd'hui sur le campus
de nokia regardez derrière vous savez le
bâtiment principal à paris saclay on est
au sud de paris pour parler 5g nokia je
me connais c'est nous qui allons donc
layadi nokia smartphone ça c'est une
ancienne histoire c'était avant s'était
vendu à achever m
washam des jeux s'est jamais parfait
apporter pas le sujet aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va parler un équipement
on va parler de réseaux on va parler de
500 appareils de nokia et de la 5g des
innovations qui va être en place
premiers mois ya beaucoup de choses
surtout il ya une vraie valeur qui est
intéressant parce que nokia maîtrise
toute la chaîne de alex est à dire qu il
parle de votre opérateur et ensuite ils
arrivent sur le terrain avec la radio
tout ce que vous avez récupéré on
signale aujourd'hui en 4g demain refusé
justement aujourd'hui on va parler de la
taxe il faut faire des choses qui sont
très intéressants des innovations vous
allez voir presque plus c'est quelque
chose de vraiment majeurs sans
changements majeurs la 5g s'est pas
uniquement le fait d'avoir plus de
vitesse de collection et moins de
latence ça va au delà de ça c'est un
changement la société qui est profond
avec de nouveaux usages qu'on n'est pas
encore aujourd'hui mais on arrive entre
apercevoir des clauses vous emmener avec
moi
paris saclay sur le campus nokia y
vivent et sont vraiment très intéressant
[Musique]
pour parler 5-0 va commencer par parler
matériel et là je vous montre un petit
peu comment ça marche
questionné sur les radios déjà
existantes 2g 3g 4g on pouvoir rajouter
la 5g et si on veut arriver directement
sur ce qu'on a directement sur la 5g on
va monter vraiment en fréquence ils
avaient la radio tout cas pur mensonge
on a derrière ça illustre bien ce qu'on
pourrait faire ce que en tout cas il se
peut qu'il arrive au niveau de la salle
gré c'est-à-dire au niveau de la smart
city la ville connectée tout est
interconnecté alors je vois si vous
connaissez un peu l'idée de la smart
cities si ça vous parle ou pas du tout
c'est d'abord une grande ville qui est
interconnecté tous les appareils
communiquent entre eux déjà la 5g ça va
être la grande révolution de ce qu'on
appelle la guillotine c'est à dire les
objets connectés tous les objets qui
communiquent entre eux au travers
d'internet alors déjà que la saint
jacques lacasse g on a franchi un pas
avec la cnds a valu beaucoup plus loin
parce que en fait les objets vont
pouvoir parler entre eux imaginez
typiquement vous êtes en ville vous avez
votre voiture qui est connecté à la 5g
directement pour avoir des dates à elle
de pouvoir communiquer en même temps
directement avec un feu donc elle saura
si la voiture devant freine pas ce
qu'est un communiqué que la hauteur
devant elle saura s'il faut de la place
rouge parce que le feu va lui dire donc
elle va pouvoir freiner toute seule là
pouvoir anticiper pas mal de choses donc
en termes de sécurité déjà c'est
vachement bien puis surtout ça pouvoir
n'est de poste des objets intelligents
il a publiquement un petit robot qui va
pouvoir savoir s'il ya des voitures a
ajouté celui qui a pouvoir connaître des
pailles de circuler faille va récupérer
beaucoup de données ça promet en tout
cas une vision de l'avenir qui est assez
intéressante pour déléguer des tâches
qui sont pas forcément hyper
intéressante alors le petit robot ce qui
fait sur le campus de nokia et livre des
colis de moins de 5 kg c'est assez
pratique parce qu'en fait vous avez des
petits casiers dans lequel on met les
colis les personnes qui doivent recevoir
leur colis
et bien quand leur bois proches à leur
envoie un sms avec un petit code pin
il arrive en bas ils vont taper leur
code pin ça ouvre le bon tiroirs et
récupèrent leurs paquets et retourne
bosser donc là pour un sens à vivre
uniquement à l'extérieur mais imaginez
l'idée de justement de la 5g c'est que
vous avez un petit robot qui fait
l'extérieur mais vous pourriez avoir un
deuxième robot qui prend le relais qui
va à l'intérieur ou alors pourquoi pas
un seul même robot qui fait extérieur
intérieur et qui vous livrent
directement votre bureau c'est un gain
de productivité vous parlez pas tant
depuis sept étages sont un peu ingrate
et qui sont déléguées directement à ces
petites machines a donc c'est assez
intéressant par contre ça demande à voir
des techniques sont vraiment vraiment au
point notamment le fait de vous dire ok
votre beau quand il va rentrer à
l'intérieur comment il va savoir où est
ce que vous êtes en rien au foot avec
une petite caméra d'accord mais pas que
pas uniquement il va être en mesure de
pouvoir cartographier l'intérieur du
bureau connaître l'endroit où ils
allaient apprendre progresser savoir où
vous livrer dans des conditions hors du
contexte ça c'est vraiment intéressant
et surtout des portes et tout le côté un
peu intelligent dans un club parce qu'il
va communiquer directement saint jean au
qu'on va voir des robots je dirais un
peu des carcasses vide un peu bête mais
où toute la partie
selligent ce das faire ailleurs hors du
datacenter et c'est un peu tout ça
l'enjeu de la 5 c'est à dire la terre
connectabilité sais pas si c'est le bon
terme au niveau de la smart cities au
niveau de la ville collecter tous les
objets vont communiquer les uns aux
autres ça peut être probablement une
dévotion d étape importante pour
l'évolution de la robotique dans les
années à venir
le fait d'avoir tous ces objets qui
communiquent les uns aux autres c'est en
tout cas entrevoir de belles
perspectives
ça lui dit branche grand public est ce
que ça m'apporte tout ça en fait
qu'est-ce que je peux faire avec la 5g
et le club donc en fait la 5g et le clad
ça va permettre en fait de d'allouer les
ressources au plus près du besoin de
l'utilisateur
donc par exemple dans cet exemple si
l'utilisateur et d'abonnés a par exemple
un il veut se rendre au stade de france
et il veut il a souscrit une offre où il
va pouvoir utiliser des lunettes de
réalité virtuelle
ok pour avoir accès à des informations
de stats ou de replay en fait cet abonné
il va il va prendre le bus quand il
arrive à la gare est en fait quand il va
prendre le bus il va pouvoir commencer à
regarder sa tablette regarder des vidéos
de l'entraînement etc mais par contre il
est servi pour l'instant par un cloud
centralisée et donc les performances ne
se peut être pas suffisante pour
vraiment lui offrir les par exemple de
la réalité virtuelle et donc en fait en
5 j je vais être capable de suivre le
bus et je vais me rendre compte que le
bus se rapproche du stade de france
et à partir moment où le bus va être au
plus près du stade de france donc sous
la couverture radio 2 qui couvre le
stade de france je vais automatiquement
basculer les ressources dans un
datacenter qui se trouve près du stade
de france voire même dans les bâtiments
les locaux du stade de france
ok pour lui offrir cette meilleure
qualité de service et qui vont supporter
notamment ses applications de type 1
donc là tels la géolocalisation et tu va
rajouter plus de performance pour un
service dédié en fait aimer c'est
surtout que dynamiquement je peux
changer la localisation de mes services
et à dire ce n'est pas statique on a
bien vu qu'au début mon service était
rendu dans un club national oui et au
fur et à mesure que le bus se
rapprochait à un moment donné je décide
à tient maintenant je suis suffisamment
proche du stade je vais pouvoir
transférer une partie des ressources et
notamment
mais tout ce qui est le user plein
fonctionne vraiment le tuyau qui va
délivrer de service ce tuyau là mais
plutôt que de le rendre dans un noeud
central qui peut être pro
potentiellement loin du stade
je vais décider de la louer au plus
proche du stade pour garantir les
paramètres de qualité
[Musique]
à des trucs intéressants si avec la 5g
c'est que à la différence de la 4g par
exemple lorsque vous voulez identifier
localiser quelqu'un vous avez ce qu'on
appelle de la triangulation vous prenez
trois bandes différentes vous arrivez à
voir la position de quelqu'un avec plus
ou moins de précision avec la sagesse
est relativement différent
vous prenez une seule antenne et avec
une sorte un roux vous avez un découpage
du signal au niveau de l'antenne
si vous permet de savoir exactement dans
quelle zone se situe la personne vous
arrivez à la géo localisé à une petite
distance près alors on se rende pas dans
la paranoïa par tous est fliqué à savoir
où est-ce qu'on attend gauche par contre
ça peut être intéressant pour les forces
d'ordre lorsqu'à des enquêtes
effectivement été abattu à cette
personne était là et je sais très
précisément ça ça peut être plutôt cool
mais en fait si on réfléchit un peu plus
loin il ya des usages plus en terme de
marketing on peut imaginer ça ne s'était
pas encore mais imaginez vous avez une
application dans lequel vous vous dites
ok dans ma ville je fais du shopping
quand je suis à 50 mètres d'une boutique
que j'aime bien que j'ai sélectionné et
qu'elle a une opération commerciale ou
une solde en tout cas intéressant et
bien ça ne l'envoie sur l'application ou
est quelque chose qui se passe ça me
l'ouvragé l'info vous balader en ville
tient pas telle boutique fait ça tel
moment haye et l animation
il ya tel truc culturel ou pas à
distance eh bien ça voulant pas
directement qu'on se prépare est aussi
de travailler le marketing de façon un
petit peu différente ça peut être
intéressant puisque vous avez vraiment
une géolocalisation qui est très
précises grâce à la 5g quant à toutes
les antennes du site qui sont
positionnés là les antennes principal et
l'est où 5 g
trois missiles sur les antennes verte
donc vers le toit pourrait force de la
tour donc l'âge et au kansas et palissy
en orange on a les antennes 28 giga
hockey dispose et qui sont plus petites
donc au niveau rayonnement et qui sont
positionnées sur le bâtiment copernic et
sur le bâtiment froid vieux d'urgence et
en bleu les ans les futures antennes fdd
sans qu'elles en attente d'autorisation
justement de marseille ok donc ça c'est
toute la couverture du site nokia paris
saclay en 5 j'ai donc c'est vraiment une
zone de test l'on va expérimenter la 5g
sur les nouveaux usages
l'ag bordeaux par un peu alors on
déborde du site sur la cellule ils se
trouvent
en eau d'image ouais ce qui nous permet
d'ailleurs d'aller faire des drive test
avec notre vam votre ford mustang ouvrir
60 beauval en puissance et au vannes oc
n'a j'aime bien le vin de formule 3 et 6
ans quand même un peu plus loin il faut
savoir qu'au niveau de la télévision
pourra pas avoir de l'a8 quarantaine thé
chantant dacquois trois ou quatre
chaînes maximum qui pourrait le
supporter en tout cas et donc du coup
pour pallier un pasa et pour que dans
quelques années alors c'est pas encore
le cas on a encore le temps tout le
monde n'est pas encore en cas de kala
huit cas ce n'est pas encore pour demain
mais ça arrive et ça va très très vite
on se projette dans aller dans cinq ans
imazighen l'a8 caillet l'été les 8 4
partout le tarif est intéressant tout le
monde à la 5g et bien oui nord la télé
par la tnt où vous soyez [ __ ] pour
l'instant en tout cas avec les techno
actuelle et bien vous pourriez avoir
votre télé directement en salle g ça
peut être un sujet assez intéressant
emmanuel pas être plus intéressant de
montrer ici on travaille sur le futur de
l'humain oui le futur de l'entreprise et
notre objectif c'est d'augmenter
l'humain avec des deux artistes et
bouira volts l'accord auquel a cédé
prototype b l'aps donc on a développé
mon appel l'iphone c'est quoi ce petit
produire du coup c'est la gueule donc
c'est un censeur que l'on place au
niveau de l'oreille d'accord qui
comporte une caméra qui fait qu'elle
vient de côté qui agissent là voilà tout
à fait ok de la reconnaissance vocale
qui a un speaker et donc qui permet
d'interagir avec les god
et puis de films et on va dire
l'environnement est donc cet exode est
connectée à notre plate forme humaine
augmentation alors qu'ils embarquent des
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
qui vont lui permettre de fournir de
l'information nécessaire l'utilisateur
qui va porter c'est quoi les cas lisez à
ce que tu peux faire des centaines alors
deux cas d' usage par exemple on peut
faire de la localisation indoor c'est à
dire à l'intérieur du bâtiment
c'est à dire que la la caméra va envoyer
l'information la photo de l'endroit où
se situe à la plateforme et la
plateforme à lui lui dire le sa
localisation à l'intérieur d'un bâtiment
dans quels usages deuxième cas l usage
c'est qu'on a des algorithmes de
reconnaissance faciale
on peut être pas rentrer dans un meeting
au sein de l'entreprise et cette
application là va nous dire à l'oreille
le nom des personnes que l'on a en face
de soi ça ça m'arrive souvent soir et de
ne plus savoir qui est qui voilà que ça
remplace les amis qu'ils dansaient telle
personne
voilà c'est ok donc il ya produit là il
y en avait eu que tu veux montrer à tout
à fait donc on a là ce qu'on appelle la
slim donc c'est un manchon que l'on met
au niveau du bras hockey qui comporte de
nombreux capteurs ou qu'on a ici à une
caméra qui dans le ce cas là nous donne
la localisation est tombé dedans on a
des capteurs qui mesurent la fréquence
il ya un petit moment
d'ailleurs c'est moi là dedans donc on a
des capteurs qui mesurent la fréquence
cardiaque
ouais le mouvement nomination
atmosphérique les gestes dans l'espace
mais aussi les gestes qu'on appelle la
mesure de le mg c'est à dire les la
mesure du muscle et les gestes des mains
la con qu'on utilise par exemple pour
faire la commande de drones ou la
commande de robots mobiles
si tu nous tendrons un robot directement
des mouvements de la main comme ça voilà
tout à fait
donc ils sont deux d'autres cas
d'application du port et le judo depuis
ce que tu imagines tu te regardes un
petit peu loin seront produits comme ça
au grand public qu'est ce qu'on peut
imaginer
et bien ici comment on peut commander
bas commander son sa chaîne hi-fi
commander son son sa télévision
uniquement à partir de gestes dessus de
manière embarquez donc les drones ça
c'est déjà existants en gros on est
ouvert à tout
faudrait imaginer sur un horrible un peu
plus fins caché à bras ce n'est
peut-être pas ce sont des prototypes de
recherche au qu'effectivement ça a
vocation à évoluer et améliorer les nra
dont classé des prototypes que l'on
utilisera fer des lames pour pour nos
expériences et là on a cas du losc est
très intéressant au niveau de la sangle
c'est à dire que là on est une petite
commande qui va actionner un objet de
l'autre côté qui est planqué la fête et
on va sentir la rugosité c'est à dire
que là on touche un truc quelque chose
qui est très rugueuse et on a la
sensation directement là alors on
pourrait se dire ils sont à côté c'est
normal ça tarde collecté moins fait non
sata connectées en 5 et donc on pourrait
imaginer à des grandes distances à
plusieurs centaines voire milliers de
kilomètres vous voulez toucher un sol
quoi que ce soit vous le commandez salle
bouge là vous avez retouches tactiques
et ça c'est un des cas d'usagé très
intéressant pour montrer ce qui manque
au mans on peut commander quelque chose
à distance grâce à la 5g
après il ya plein de cas d'usagés
différents qu'on peut imaginer alors là
on parle effectivement de nous on parle
du citoyen on peut parler aussi des
industries que ça va révolutionner aussi
pas mal de choses au niveau de
l'industrie
le fed rapporte effectivement de la
fluidité mais elle fait de simplifier
les modèles alors c'est un peu complexe
tu te va pas rentrer dans le côté
industriel mais il faut vraiment
comprendre avec la 5g sais que ça va
permettre d'avoir un modèle de société
plus évolué et plus simple lors on se
pose toujours la question effectivement
de la 5g et de la santé des risques tout
ça on en reparlera ultérieurement entre
sm quelque chose de vraiment hyper
intéressant ça donne une vision de terre
là où pour aller en tout cas notre
société et même en termes de santé par
exemple le fait d'un chirurgien puisse
opérer à distance vous pouvez sentir
quelque chose au toucher à distance en 5
j on pourrait très bien imaginer qu'un
chirurgien opère à grande distance sur
les opérations très complexe en 5 j'ai
imaginé par exemple pour les déserts
médicaux vous ayez un médecin avec une
interface robotique archers ça peut
faire un peu flipper se dire l'interface
trois boutiques mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui et des déserts médicaux
et bien vous pourriez imaginer un
médecin à distance vous voulez travers
un écran qui pourrait avoir un bras pour
prendre de tension pour faire de la
palpation ou quoi que ce soit ça montre
beaucoup de cas d' usage et c'est quand
même très intéressant
c'est marrant en fait ici sur le campus
de nokia c'est que vous n'avez pas juste
des bureaux ont fait plus que travailler
on peut aussi venir manger vous avez le
colombus café qui vivent juste ici et là
on peut faire couper les cheveux
je me dis que c'est assez pratique entre
après la pause café après avoir bossé
marine on vient sur une petite coupe
ben ouais donc c'est ici qu'en fait on
peut dire ça coupe les tifs ya beaucoup
de monde qui vient oui cool merci
beaucoup
tata comment penser toni ferrer j'aurai
donc voilà il ya beaucoup de cas d'usagé
ya beaucoup de choses qui vont arriver
beaucoup de choses qui vont développer
au niveau de la 5g et c'est plutôt cool
donc murciano cas de m'avoir accueilli
aujourd'hui ici sur le nokia campus à
paris saclay ça me permet de découvrir
beaucoup de choses de voir tous ces
usages de l'a5 j'espère que ça vous aura
vous aussi intéressés dit mot qu'est ce
que vous retenez tout ça qu'est ce qui
vous intéresse c'est ce que la 5g
vous êtes un petit peu impatients ou
impatience est ce que ça vous inquiète
marc et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaires dites moi ce que vous en
pensez
je trouve ça cool on en reparlera la
sexy parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire la 5g va arriver en 2020 en france
et va être déployée plus en plus et vous
verrez qu'il va y avoir des usages qu'on
n'imagine même pas aujourd'hui des
applications qu'on n'imagine pas lorsque
la cage est arrivé en france on
n'imaginait pas le phénomène
hubert donc on n'imagine pas ce qui
varie avec la singette mais probablement
des choses qui sont vraiment très
intéressante sur ce je vous embrasse
mais vous donne rendez vous dès demain
salut